le pavillon de la villa viardot et son
parc en hauteur sont donc désormais
inscrit au site historique ces liens 400
go bonsoir ça vous êtes là justement
pour nous en parler
alors pour ceux qui ne connaîtraient pas
encore cette célèbre villa pouvez-vous
déjà nous la présenter oui c'est une des
plus anciennes propriétés de bougival la
villa viardot a été construite en 1830
est acheté par pauline viardot grandes
cantatrices du 19e siècle
son mari louis viardot et yvan autour de
nief écrivains en russe
cette maison est désormais inscrite au
titre des monuments historiques vous
l'avez dire puisqu'elle nécessite d'être
conservés d'un point de vue dans
l'intérêt public
la villa est dégradée est laissé à
l'abandon c'est donc une bonne nouvelle
pour le président du centre européen des
musiques de possibles le fait qu elle
enfin navires dont est inscrite aux
monuments historiques absolument
extraordinaires de l'histoire de la
musique et de l'histoire de la pensée
soit préservée estoril et un coup
aujourd'hui aux monuments historiques
et cette année on fête aussi le
bicentenaire de la naissance de pauline
viardot oui elle est née le 18 juillet
1801 21 à paris malheureusement l
inauguration de la ville alberto ne se
fera pas lors de ce bicentenaire à cause
de la crise sanitaire
elle sera reportée en 2022 mais l'opéra
comique à paris et dédiera une journée
entièrement à pauline viardot le 6
octobre 2021 et donc la villa va pouvoir
accueillir du public
oui ce lieu de mémoire va s'inscrire
dans un projet de centre européen de
musique il y aura des masterclass des
concerts des conférences des expositions
qui font partie donc de ce grand projet
qui s'appelle le chantre européens qui
sont là ont 2024 et cette villa
va-t-elle reprendre vie comme à l'époque
c'est bien exactement à l'époque
justement le monde culturel et
artistique se donner rendez vous dans
cette propriété
il y a eu à emile zola george sand ou
encore ivan tourgueniev ce dernier
d'ailleurs a connu une relation à
mickeal et peut-être amoureuses ont fait
pas avec pauline viardot il était donc
souvent à bougival
il a d'ailleurs écrit depuis la villa
viardot des lettres avec gustave
flaubert que vous pouvez retrouver dans
ce livre je n'ai pas les nerfs assez
robuste pour vivre dans ce monde là
sorti il ya un mois et édité par le
passeur et remercie celles agathe sango
d'avoir été avec nous on vous retrouve
bien sûr pour le 7-8 week end qui merci